bootleg cat podcast we got special
guests all the way from Brownsville
Brooklyn USA wait I'm not from
Brownsville though oh where are you from
I'm from Brooklyn okay okay so you're
from Brooklyn wait wait wait wait we
both from Brooklyn we just had the
Brownsville conversation right see from
Brownsville she's from Brownsville right
where are you from Brooklyn Brook okay
she's from the whole Brooklyn facts just
so I'm clear Brownsville's in Brooklyn
yes I'm not a crazy person no okay so I
said Brownsville Brooklyn USA right so
she's from just shout out to BK yeah
yeah
okay that's good to know I'm from
everywhere except Brownsville and
Carroll Heights and I'm from Brownsville
Crown Heights so you're from
Williamsburg on some days yeah nice I
heard they have some good coffee there
yeah maybe they got big rats big rats
six nines from there
he was up
no I'm not I'm kidding I'm kidding is he
though I don't know isn't he from
Brooklyn no
um anyway listen we have girl code here
from New York all right girl code
I'm shot bigger
um I said
real quick before we have you guys tear
this down because I just saw y'all's
Funk Flex freestyle was special uh how'd
you guys meet how long have you guys
been a group
we met since we came out the womb
because we're sisters how y'all doing I
didn't know that well there you go yes
however we started taking you know the
music the rap wait wait wait wait wait
just rip before your sisters so aren't
you also from Brownsville no you know
life be life in exactly I see yeah but
you guys are genetic sisters that's why
they be thinking we twins but we not
twins and that's why when they be like
oh yeah I got twin celebrity we'd be
like no this is epilepsy because we're
not like twins yeah wait so were you
guys born like like you're the same age
wait so you guys are like
literal kind of twins born on the same
day no no no right that's what I'm
saying like it's not like same parents
I'm [ __ ] lost
life be life and y'all I'm lost in the
sauce right now
we'll figure that out when we do the
interview because I am very uh yeah oh
well listen we got two sisters here Girl
coats here yes
um
so you guys like you guys rap at a very
high level how like like the rap Journey
for y'all where did that start like what
age did you guys really kind of start
start writing and taking this [ __ ]
serious we actually been musicians and
personally even though we have been
musicians what made me want to take my
song right and rap and rank and rap
Sirius was seeing her take hers serious
you know like and really write in and be
in fire rapping spitting balls doing
what's not being done right now true so
I was like nah I'm about to do it and we
never thought about doing it together I
don't know why and then the one time we
did it together it was over I was like
what we could have been doing this
together this whole time right well now
you guys are doing it together right uh
anything uh just anything you guys are
promoting right now I know you guys are
uh opening up for Coast Contra tonight
in La yes we on total Coast concert
right now we dropped the EP course shop
bigger
I could go get that on oil streaming
platforms right now I was single one
time make sure y'all Replay that until
you can Replay that one time ones on one
time we got some singles coming out we
got a video coming out we got this five
freestyle that we about the body fat go
watch the [ __ ] Flex freestyle too let's
go watch the video go watch this style
go watch the sway freestyle go watch the
DJ self freestyle go watch out
interview TT tour is the sweetheart
shout out to her yes
question uh any of the OG's in New York
tapping with y'all yet all the OG's
typed right like it's like you know it's
a little something bro
and and sway hero and suede like put on
on the wrapping side on the wrap I hell
yeah and that's the thing I was about to
say it's a little crazy because we young
so you would think that we would how
young me like man young mad young mad
young that's just that great New York
term right so you'll figure it out mad
young we would be in the mix with people
that's like new and current but we with
the the OG OG she's been a first of all
Biggie Smalls is her favorite artist and
she's been around a lot of people who's
been around biggest moves like we've
been always Brothers I'm so proud of her
and yo bro right here you know I love it
and I got a chance to be ready have you
met Remy yet yes and I met Pat what's
good yeah hey yo Papu's a great guy and
Remy they're amazing we love them yeah
first of all I own like I almost fainted
when I first met Remy almost she did I
almost I and she smelled maggot and her
hands are soft like damn [ __ ]
that's something you notice I met uh
Drake and I noticed he had really soft
hands yeah and that was exactly how like
when I shook his hand I was like oh that
feels like what I expected Drake's hands
to feel like like [ __ ] pillows right
and then like and then I met her again
and I was like your hands is really soft
and she still smell maggot it's
important to smell good yeah my hands
don't be soaking I'll be smelling like
yeah so shout outs to Lolo because he
yeah right shout out to Lolo yeah maybe
smelling if you know you know yeah
all right well listen we're gonna have
you guys rap uh the ep's out appreciate
you guys pulling up thank you for having
us for sure
facts orange and green this is your
guys's colors yes like like the group
official colors or help me out here yes
she's uh um she's green and I'm orange
those are our favorite colors and we
combine so she's on on uh she's on the
assignment today you you left the
assignment yeah you know sometimes not
sometimes I'll be like you know let me
switch it up a little bit sometimes I
might even wear green sometimes okay and
sometimes I might wear orange because
you know I like it well let's get to it
let's go let's go
[Music]
okay yeah I Like
it Loud
[Music]
go crazy okay
huh listen time to flex get some [ __ ] up
both my chest keep arms and arms reached
let a freaky chop Flex champ through the
pain call me champagne mommy Lobby boys
really have some boys in your lobby in
the hood say hi Todd haters cause we
still bull pop champagne or pop a bottle
[ __ ] Perry young gotta say it's
polite put a [ __ ]
they said we Rough Around the Edges give
me Teddy I don't big kids edges good man
trying to take me out this menswear
laugh now cry later once upon a time now
they snow and shine video we do is give
him line keep them getting bright with
their skin now they test five see that's
in the same room so now they think we
equal nine got a couple dinners with
winners
mediocre won't accept it they sleeping
on weed might be narcoleptic freshman
got the seniors looking at us like who's
this exit match my fly went and got the
new fit six break bones huh people got
some crew lips friction if you rub me
wrong [ __ ] who you cool with don't
nobody hold enough weight to make peace
[Music]
say hi
about that you're an [ __ ] why are you
with the front so I told him kiss the
back hole listen that's the girl code
[ __ ] is they talking about that's how we
treating pretty
and we the girl
goodness ladies that was amazing thank
you that was incredible go follow that
Mia shout out to ig and all that yes
everything at
t-h-e-g-i-r-l-l-c-o-d-e-e don't forget
the two L's never forget the two
ah you guys are [ __ ] incredible thank
you
you guys were just built for this [ __ ]
man thank you
[Applause]
Round of Applause that was amazing thank
you hey you just watched a crazy
freestyle and we dropped one every week
sometimes more than once a week uh and
they're always presented by our family
at LRG now I love LRG I'm wearing look
I'm gonna just show you the new shorts I
got from them check out them shorts my
boy you know what I'm saying and got the
plain black tea the plain black lrgt you
know what I mean listen lrg's back they
just dropped the crazy Jason hoodie with
Jadakiss that's from my 2008 for
Halloween [ __ ] Flames go to the
website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you 30 off when you use
the promo code bootleg 30 percent off
that's a significant amount of money
you're going to be saving when you go to
lrg's website Christmas is coming save
30 off just by going to the website and
using the promo code bootleg L Dash R
g.com we'll see you next week with a
crazy freestyle